La suma de 4 enteros impares
consecutivos es igual a 136.
¿Cuáles son esos 4 enteros?
Antes de que empecemos a resolver esto, vamos a pensar en lo que significa enteros impares consecutivos,
¿a qué se refiere, 4 enteros impares consecutivos?
Para entender esto podemos empezar con 3,
digamos que tenemos este 3
y el siguiente entero impar sería 5, el siguiente es 7 y
el número impar que sigue después de éste es 9.
Estos son enteros impares consecutivos y vamos
a ver otro ejemplo.
Si empezamos con el 11, el siguiente entero impar es 13, el siguiente es 15 y el que sigue es 17.
Un ejemplo de enteros impares no consecutivos
sería, digamos, 3, seguido por el 7,
estos no son consecutivos, el siguiente entero impar después del 3 es el 5 y no 7.
Estos son ejemplos de enteros impares consecutivos y este es un ejemplo de enteros impares no consecutivos.
Después de ver esto, vamos a resolver esta
pregunta y los invito a que pausen el video
y traten de resolverla por ustedes mismos
antes de que yo lo haga.
Como pueden imaginar vamos a usar un poco
de álgebra, así que digamos que "x"
es el entero más pequeño de los 4 enteros impares,
sea "x" el más pequeño de los 4 enteros
y vamos a expresar los otros 3 en términos de "x", así que podemos usar estos ejemplos que tenemos aquí.
Si este es "x",
¿cómo expresaríamos el siguiente en términos de "x"?
Bueno, pues este sería "x" más 2, el siguiente
entero impar es igual al anterior más 2,
lo que estamos haciendo es saltar el siguiente
número que es un número par,
si tenemos un número impar, el que sigue es un número
par, así que para saltarlo debemos sumar 2
y si sumamos otros 2, tenemos "x" más 4
y si sumamos otros 2 a eso, tendremos "x" más 6.
Y vemos eso nuevamente en este ejemplo, si
este número es "x", éste es "x" más 2,
éste otro es "x" más 4 y éste es "x" más 6.
En general, si "x" es el más pequeño de
los 4 impares, podemos definir los otros 3
como "x" más 2, "x" más 4 y "x" más 6 y
podemos sumarlos e igualarlos a 136,
así que el primero, el más pequeño es "x", el
siguiente es "x" más 2, el que sigue es "x" más 4
y el que sigue después de éste es "x" más 6
y aquí tenemos la suma de los cuatro
entero impares consecutivos.
Y nos dicen que la suma de estos 4 es igual
a 136, así que lo igualamos a 136
y lo que podemos hacer literalmente es despejar "x"
y tenemos solamente una incógnita,
vamos a sumar las "x" que tenemos aquí, una "x",
dos "x", tres "x" y cuatro "x"
y podemos reescribirlo como "4x" y luego tenemos 2 más 4 que es igual a 6
más 6 nos da 12 y entonces tenemos "4x"
más 12 es igual a 136.
Ahora vamos a despejar "x" y dejar este término
de un lado de la ecuación y quitar este 12
y para deshacernos de este 12, tenemos que
restar 12 de este lado de la ecuación
y no podemos hacer esto solo del lado
izquierdo de la ecuación
porque entonces esta igualdad ya no se cumpliría.
Estos términos eran iguales antes de restar
12 y si queremos que sigan siendo iguales
estos dos lados de la ecuación, entonces
tenemos que restar 12 del lado derecho también.
Vamos a restar 12 de los dos lados de la ecuación.
Así que de este lado restamos 12, 12 menos
12 se anulan y nos queda solamente "4x"
y del otro lado tenemos 136 menos 12, es igual a 124.
¿Y ahora, cuál es el valor de "x"?
Pues vamos a dividir los dos lados entre 4,
así que dividimos el lado izquierdo entre 4
y el lado derecho entre 4 y obtenemos "x" del lado izquierdo y de este lado tenemos 124 entre 4,
100 dividido entre 4 es igual a 25 y luego 24 dividido entre 4 es igual a 6,
así que 25 más 6 es igual a 31, de
este lado tenemos 31.
Si les cuesta un poco de trabajo hacer esta
división en la mente, pueden hacerla de la
manera tradicional, entonces tenemos 124 entre 4,
el 4 no cabe en 1, entonces tomamos el 12
y el 4 cabe en el 12, 3 veces, 3 por 4
es igual a 12 y restamos
y ahora bajamos el siguiente dígito que es 4 y 4 cabe una vez en 4, 4 por 1 es 4, restamos y el residuo es 0.
"x" es igual a 31 y "x" es el más pequeño de los 4 enteros, esta "x" de aquí es igual a 31,
"x" más 2 es igual a 33, "x" más 4 es
igual a 35 y "x" más 6 es igual a 37.
Así que nuestros 4 enteros impares consecutivos
son 31, 33, 35 y 37.